je n'ai rien contre la modernité mais ça
ne marche pas problème c'est qu'on peut
voir du tout prenez les mêmes donc
focale télémétriques oui c'est mieux
que j'ai pas sa grâce à suivre à la
trace tout ça c'est à dire est qu'un
générique ma chambre est beaucoup plus
grande d'accord
oss 117 est de retour pour des aventures
toujours aussi rocambolesques désolé je
crois que c'est mon taxi
toujours aussi professionnel toujours
aussi explosive
ce ballon
toujours aussi ravageur toujours aussi
délicat
intel est toujours aussi diplomate le
temps d'enfiler mon costume colonial
blanc clair pourquoi cette fois ce sont
17 le 4 août au cinéma